je dois avant de passer à la météo et
aux tirs c'est à la fin de ce journal
revient sur la politique vous savez que
ce soir chez nos confrères de tf1 le
président de la république participait à
une émission spéciale et à une question
qu'on lui posait sur le fait de savoir
pourquoi
à trois mois des élections législatives
une élection qui ne concerne pas at il
dit directement pourquoi est bien monté
t-il ainsi directement en première ligne
vous savez qu'il a donné récemment une
conférence de presse le 21 novembre
qu'il a parlé pendant deux heures à la
radio au début de cette semaine et donc
ce soir encore à la télévision pendant
plus d'une heure et bien voici la
réponse du président de la république
monsieur françois mitterrand à cette
question monsieur je n'ai pas
l'impression que la copa initiative a
déjà commencé avec ses seins pétarade de
tous les côtés alors non moi je suis
très intéressé par législatives je suis
vraiment très solidaire du travail qui a
été accompli pendant ces quatre ans et
demi
j'en suis d'ailleurs le principal
responsable au fond les français qui ont
tu as à se plaindre c'est un mois qui
doit s'adresser les français qui ont
aussi quelques joies ou quelques
satisfactions de ce qui a été fait
peut-être vont-ils m'en rendre
témoignage mais je suis responsable je
suis responsable je ne fais pas tout il
ya un gouvernement qui gouverne il y a
une majorité parlementaire qui fait son
travail il ya une opinion mais je suis
le premier responsable de ce qui se fait
c'est pas coup d'état nous non pas
permanent mais actuelle non mais pas du
tout je ne fais pas tout mais je
revendique la responsabilité de ce qui
est fait je ne vais pas me cacher
derrière un arbre oublier une certaine
façon c'est un autre monde et je pense
que le premier devoir d'un président de
la république c'est d'aborder avec
courage les échéances qu'il doit
affronter